started I want to welcome a new member
of the committee uh representative
mrai thanks uh for joining us I guess
we're going to have some other new
members but they're not here today and
I'll let Carol take care of that when uh
when they're here okay I'm going to open
the public hearing on House Bill
274 and I call on uh
the sponsor for this amendment
Maguire can't hear the is it on there
you
go wasn't firm enough so yes I'm Carol
Maguire representing marac District
27 and I'm presenting Amendment
2293 to House Bill
274 when we heard this in the spring
there was a quite a bit of opposition
from various agencies that didn't think
they should be included in the
bill or Exempted or included in
rulemaking
um I worked with the prime sponsor to
review those agencies and in most cases
their testimony was that they were not
entirely state agencies they
were they were in a kind of limbo
created so that they would comply with
Federal rules and laws rather than State
rules and laws
and if they were subjected to the
administrative rulemaking act they would
be considered state agencies and
therefore would not be eligible for the
large quantities of federal money that
they were Distributing
so I I couldn't see including them in
this bill we also included from the
original House Bill
274 some
Clauses that
um were easy to implement we put them in
house
bills 357 I think it was and so that
included the requirement that every um
rule making register be sent to every
member of the legislature
and also that when there were public
comments on a rule the agency had to
report to Jael car what those comments
were and how they handled
them so what's left of 274 after
deleting all those agencies are a couple
of cases
where the sponsor and I felt that we
wanted to to strengthen than legislative
oversight so if you look at the
amendment part one when they're sending
out notice of
rulemaking they have to send it to known
stakeholders which we hope will settle a
common complaint that the professional
organizations if in case of
lenses
or um known lobbyists or whatever don't
get the not of Ru
making and so that's something that
we're um we think should be fixed and
these days when they're sending the
notices out by email it doesn't cost a
whole lot more to send out 200 notices
than 50 so that's there and also they
will specifically send notice if the
it's a rule implementing new
legislation which is the time that the
legislature most
wants to be present because that's the
time when the first interpretation of
legislative intent is made into the rule
and it's most important that it be
congruent with the legislative intent
envisioned by the
legislature so they'll send that
out and that's part part one part two is
in the case where an
agency
is normally when they're either doing a
major rewrite or um implementing new
legislation they might go out for
comment prior to having a draft of the
rule it h so they'll work with people on
you know what are the issues and this
one says that that when they're doing
this there they solicit comments they
also solicit comments from the
legislative policy committee it so uh if
Dees is writing a new water
rule or they're working on a major
revision they would deal with
resources if oplc is deciding they're
going to totally rewrite their uh
investigative procedures they might
solicit our comment that sort of thing
um but again this is only in the case
where they're soliciting information
they just have to include the
legislature and the third one is
right now if the if Del car makes a
final objection to a rule for whatever
appropriate reason it chooses but
doesn't vote to submit a um joint
resolution to be approved by the full
legislature the agency can implement the
rule except that
they do not have the assumption that
they are interpreting the legislature
correctly they have to to prove that
they are provide meeting the
requirements of the
legislature this doesn't happen all that
often but it does happen and so this
goes on to say that if a if someone sues
to say this rule does not meet
legislative intent or it's got some
other uh effect the judge the court can
rule that the the rule is invalid and
this amendment simply says that in that
fees uh so it's a two rare cases piled
on top of each other but um yeah we
thought it would encou it would
discourage agencies from adopting rules
that
are usually very controversial because
that's the case where jail car can
submit a final objection but not submit
a
u
uh P
petition thank you
so so that was U these are the three
changes that this amendment would make
to um the administrative rulemaking
process simply to get more legislative
involvement
early and then if a rule is is judged
invalid there's also a monetary penalty
namely they pay the uh the plaintiff's
legal
fees it completely replaces everything
else that was in House Bill
274 and if there's any questions I'll be
glad to answer them any questions from
the
committee ah
yes
sure thank you Mr chair um I see that
the sponsor s on this bill some of whom
are shall we say Heavy Hitters in the
legislature are they all on board with
uh this amendment do you
know I I believe so I've only spoken to
there the uh the sponsor is still
working on the question of can a um a
committee o is it constitutional for a
sub Committee of the legislature act in
the case place of the full legislature
but that is not included here um I'm
shows but she's happy with this any
other questions to
committee represent
gr thank you I'm in support of your of
the amendment um I do think it's
important that we work out how the
legislative subcommittee
on rule making interact with and I with
the Committees themselves and it might
be that depending on what the committee
who the committee is there might be a
you know there might be um targeted
approach for each of these um
legislative subcommittees and their
committees based on R making and their
tendency to get
involved okay but that's a matter of
house rules is how the how the sub
committee's work this would simply
require
notice and from there how the how it's
implemented is up to US Representative
Schmidt thank you Mr chairman uh and
representative McGuire thank you very
much for your thoughtful Amendment uh I
I my my question uh will go to the
aspect of workability because uh
as you know uh the Jael car meets at
least once a month um year round but the
legislature is effectively kind of not
participatory for about half the year uh
in the first year and the second year is
white largely impacted by the upcoming
election process so how much the the
policy committee would be available is
an issue and it is yes it is an issue I
am expecting that during the offseason
well actually even even during the main
season we'll be lucky if you get one or
two people on the committee to actually
read the rules this doesn't Force the
legislature to do anything it merely
gives them the opportunity to be
involved and I think we need to continue
with the the education to convince
people that when you've got your bill
passed you're not done if it requires
rul making you'd better get involved in
the rules so if there if it's if the
rule is created by new
legislation I would expect the
sponsor and the CH and maybe somebody
else to get involved followup follow up
thank you uh so um there there already
is as you know a process by which PE
stakeholders would be impacted by these
rules uh are invited to participate
incourage to participate in the
formation of the rules by the by the
agency that will be o charged with
overseeing them um uh and uh and that
culminates in a in a public hearing
after the agency has gotten its uh stuff
together uh before that rule even goes
to the jel car attorneys for their
vetting of the rule uh and then a public
hearing as part of the jel car process
but is it your hope that that by this
informational process that the that you
that you've been speaking to that it
will encourage more stakeholders to get
informed to get involved because the
more they bring up issues of workability
of a rule and so forth the better we
should wind up having a workable rule uh
when it when it comes to time for the
the final product to come before J
you're you're exactly right by getting
the the
stakeholders and the PE the people in
the legislature that are trying to
change the law that the rule implements
getting them
involved at the
preliminary rule level or or
before is way more effective and it's
easier for the
agency all right it getting if they get
the comments in from the the sponsor of
the bill that created the rule saying uh
this is pretty good except this one
section doesn't doesn't do what I
thought it ought to
do you know that that's where I hope
that the that the comments can be useful
is when they Iden identify places where
the agency has made an assumption that
wasn't worn out and it's within the
scope of the law so that the jail car
attorneys will say yep that's
legal but you might have to deal with
intent one more followup thank thank you
Mr chairman um so one of the aspects um
that that is uh is troubling to all of
us who are you know involved in the
process as you and I are on the Jael car
is um this interaction uh at when the
attorneys bring us their work product um
but one of the things that you
referenced in your testimony was that
final objections are quite rare do you
have any information with regard to how
often I've been on the Jael car now for
about 17 years uh and and I it seems to
me like final objections are quite rare
do do you have any statistical
information on that no just uh that like
you it doesn't I remember two in 11
there's one about the medic from the
medical board and they changed their
rules eventually to figure to clear it
up and then there was objection to the
uh medical
malpractice uh fund that was sustained
because you the point that you raised is
very valid that uh that the courts have
already held that uh that if the if
there's been a final objection and the
agency has implemented the rule over the
final objection of the Jael car that the
state uh will not back up the agency
they're on their own to demonstrate that
that rule in fact is
constitutional so forth so right um but
I it would be interesting for me to know
if we could get out of
oplc uh how of and final because it's
not from op from uh it would be from
legislative
Services that's correct um I will try to
have that information for for Thursday
because as you stated the the the um
joint resolution stops a rule that the
jail car attorneys uh and the jail car
uh just will not accept uh and but that
does have to pass both bodies to to
become law so that's pretty pretty
uncommon as well because the agencies
usually do try to accommodate the Jael
cars objections and and come up with a
rule that that the legislative
side can can approve so yeah but this I
think can be helpful the only time I
remember that a rule was implemented
over a final objection without a joint
resolution was the first uh learn
everywhere rules
where um gel the majority of Jael car
voted to make a final resolution but but
there weren't enough votes to submit a
joint resolution so those were
implemented it was a partisan issue
entirely unrelated to the
the so that I remember that happening
but that's I there were very very few
other I will try and find out any other
questions with the committee
see none is there anyone here uh who
would anyone else would like to speak on
uh this amendment to
274 okay seeing none I'm going to close
the uh hearing on the amendment to House
Bill 274 and I think we've got about a
next
all
back I'm opening the hearing on
Amendment
2349 to House Bill 58 and I call
Representative
groa thank you madam chair
um House Bill 518 which originally was
establishing a commission to study
revisions of Occupational regulations of
Pharmacists and pharmacies was retained
by our committee with the thought that
we would be using it as a vehicle for a
non non- gerain Amendment having to do
with the modifications that were brought
about uh in oplc through House Bill 655
655 as you may recall was a rather large
bill and we took different um we took it
in bite-size
pieces and there were these small
um elements that were left behind that
need to be changed in order to make the
current statute harmonious with the um
changes that we made in House Bill
655 so that's where this amendment um
2349 would be Place House Bill
518 and um
the I don't know if you've had a chance
to read it but it does talk about how um
the license fee um collection how
licenses will be reinstated where this
used to be done by the board this is all
being done by oplc now and RSA 310 is
going to be um the RSA that all of these
um
legislative components um will be
found um I think there are people here
from oplc who can answer any further
questions I believe there is
one um one word that needs to be changed
which Miss which I missed I apologize
and I think ah there you are hang for
thanks it's on page two and it's um page
line 26 where it says holders of lapsed
licenses so that sentence makes more
sense because we do say earlier that
laps
licenses
um I mean sorry expired licenses shall
not be able to renew all right so that's
where that's the only change that we
think needs to be done correct yeah are
there any
questions always a lot of questions when
bills thank you Madame chair
uh on what uh repres the representative
brought up on line 26 on page two I I
can accept that uh but I just wonder
what would be the flavor of this
committee you know because where we
needed to draft another amendment Madam
chair on this and uh can we give it sort
of like the green light if that's the
only change that is to be made because
it seems like an awful lot of work went
into this yes we
should we're meeting again on Wednesday
to vote on this today is the hearing so
we should debate whether this is what we
intend and if so can we get enough
another amendment that fixes it and but
for now it's she's saying her intent is
that it's for expired
um well it makes if you read the
sentence before it says expired licenses
shall elapse for one year from
expiration and holders of expired
licenses so it's a it's a continuation
of that but I'm sure we can get it
redrafted okay and so so to clarify the
intent is that for one year after their
license expires they may apply for renal
correct if it's been more than a year
they've got to take some extra steps
correct okay thank you representative
Dolan yes thank you madam chair I as one
Committee Member I would indeed support
that edit uh going forward thank you
okay repres
Mani thank you madam chair I said I was
not going to to make a comment but
having um had a profession where I had
to get licensed for 35 plus years um you
know it was that onee Gap I mean onee
grace period is very helpful because you
get the renewal the previous year
December if you miss it you forget about
it used to be twoyear renewal window and
so that really helps if it wasn't for
that one year I would have a harder time
okay thank you any other questions
comments thank you very
much all right I think we time to bring
up OPC and the heavy
guns Mr Oster house and director
cordney yes representative Schmidt thank
you madam chair looking at page two uh
line
of uh line
8 uh is a kind of a linguistic tangle
here I think there's something
grammatically wrong or a word
missing uh or maybe I'm not able to read
it in my Advanced age uh lensy
possessing a license in good standing
May if to the best of the lenes
knowledge is what's the subject of is
question
ly I think what you're saying is there
should be a comma after
knowledge no you need you need a noun a
ver a noun there or a pronoun the
license he possessing May if the best of
their knowledge they are
not that that that phrasing makes some
sense this just doesn't work very well
or it's going to be hard for people to
really know what it means yes okay so
that needs to be reworked I think thank
you the intent of that was to clarify
that if the office has gone through the
bother of collecting of evaluating your
application and then denying
it not I get I get that part but okay
all right yes grammatically it looks
like they need a they or something in
that all right any other questions for
representative
pra all right thank you very much okay
thank
you good morning Madame chair members of
the committee I am Lindsay Courtney
executive director oplc with me is oplc
general counsel Douglas
osterhout um so thank you for the
opportunity to speak on behalf of the
amendment to HB
518 um which is essentially just uh
further cleanup of opl's uh codification
efforts last session um the first part
of this is really intended to clarify
when licenses expire versus when they're
able to reinstate I will say
historically some boards had been able
to do uh a late renewal as opposed to a
re a late reinstatement um and this
meant that after they their license
expired they were permitted to renew
their license up to a certain period of
time the challenge with that is that the
licens uh issuance would back dat to
their original period of lure which um
which misrepresented a period of
potential unlicensed practice so last
year uh the statute was changed to make
it clear that licenses expired at their
expiration date and may be subject to
reinstatement but with the clarification
between the terms lapse and expire the
intent is to make clear how long a
lensey can reinstate and that obviously
is a policy decision up to you um what's
represented here is a period of
reinstatement for a year um which is
pretty typical but um obviously that's
something for you to consider the other
thing that this bill does is it defines
good standing which is a term that we
use last here in HB
594 um but it was not defined in statute
so I thought we should probably Define
statute the other major
um change that this bill proposes to
accomplish is to make clear that our
presiding officers can and should assist
the boards with um presiding over
non-disciplinary adjudicate adjudicative
proceedings
so last session we um were able to
obtain legislation that directed our
presiding officers who are lawyers to
preside over disciplinary proceedings
but there are hearings that we have um
for which are not disciplinary in nature
there are licensing proceedings and then
non-disciplinary remedial proceedings
and I would like to say that the process
is going very well um and so I think
that it makes sense to further require
present officers to assist the boards in
that regard and there's no real policy
reason why I think we would want to
distinguish between those two types of
proceedings so this proposed uh
Amendment would make that change as well
um and then finally I think on page five
and uh this is there the same change is
made throughout the bill in a couple of
different um places but we have run into
circumstances in which a board cannot
meet Quorum and has not been been able
to meet Quorum and the question becomes
what is our what are our legal remedies
when there is no board for example the
board of registration of medical
technicians has not met in I believe two
years we have a number of complaints uh
two of which were uh considered
emergencies and there's nothing the
agency or the state can do other than to
try to fill the board position so this
would uh allow a situation in those rare
circumstances for the agency to act
um if the board is not uh if there is no
board um and then I said final but I
will say final again on page seven um
last
year uh in a couple of different
practice acts the what we call charging
language for discipline was
repealed um with the with the idea that
the original version of hp2 650 655 and
then 409 included some charging language
it didn't end up um being included in
the final version and so we think that
there needs to be some General charging
language for what could constitute
misconduct for all professions and then
the board still retain the authority to
further clarify that in rules or rely on
their own practice acts but there should
at least be some general C charging
language and that's included on page
else yes okay
no I'm happy to answer any questions
certain representative sha has a
question yes I I think uh another tweak
on page five line
18 um direct that evidence be sole
received solely I think that should be
yeah
18 yeah should be received solely by a
presiding
officer that's the problem with having
e representative leus sorry um so I'm
noticing on line 18 it's received solely
and if we make that change solely Oh by
a presiding officer and below the next
line The Authority given to the
matter looks like those should be the
same so whichever
way
it's it just looks odd probably meaning
is
fine it should probably be the yeah all
right any other questions representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so uh you
referenced earlier in your excuse me in
your testimony Madam director um
that situations where it's
remedial but not
disciplinary so that strikes me as a
kind of
a a gray area that is that well defined
it may be that something is not being
done right but it's not illegal
or awful or what destructive or whatever
in which case I mean but the question
is how did it happen just ineffective
practice is that well defined yes it's
defined in our statute and it
essentially is intended to Encompass the
circumstances in which typically happens
if somebody starts to experience
cognitive uh deficiencies it may not be
fit to practice but it's not necessarily
I mean you could bring a disciplinary
action but you don't necessarily want to
because the issue is not um did they
commit misconduct the issue is at some
point we have to re-evaluate their
current Fitness to practice so that
those are usually the
circumstances um and they're few and far
Thompson
good morning Madame chair members of the
committee my name is Simon Thompson I am
a contract lobbyist with shien finny
Capital group here today on behalf of uh
one of your favorite members of the
public Steve ranor from ecba the
electrical contractor Business
Association uh he could not make it
today to provide some feedback and ask
that I do uh many of the the items or a
couple of the items that I was going to
bring up I think have been addressed but
I'm going to just rein restate them just
so we're we're um all on the same page
representative fellows you caught one of
the the the typos on page five line 18
you change B to buy I think that also
needs to happen on page six line 16 same
thing I think it must have probably just
been a a cut and paste yes indeed thank
you for catching
that
um
so going back to page one in the uh
issue of uh reinstatement and re U
versus renewal after your license
expires so how it is set up is that your
license expires today tomorrow week from
today you could you could uh pay a late
fee and get your license renewed we we
just want to make sure that with this
new language that if I my license
expires and a couple of days later a
couple weeks later we uh get our license
reinstated that we're not paying uh
renewal fee and a reinstatement fee as
it's set up right now we renew our
license and if we're late we pay 50
bucks we just want to make sure that
it's not a reinstatement fee and a
renewal fee I did consult with with
director Courtney uh prior to uh this
meeting and she said that it's not but I
just wanted to make sure that that is
brought up and and that we can get some
a confirmation on that additionally uh
in that section uh starting on line 27
page one we would request a potential of
a 60-day grace period uh prior to for
for many many many many years your
license renewed on your birthday kind of
like when you need to get your car
inspected that's something you know I
don't really think about getting my car
inspected oh it's October it's my
birthday I got to get it inspected so
now it's just a date and and with all
that's going on licenses sometimes just
forget that date and they've asked for
uh or are requesting um kind of a grace
period uh I I'm throwing out 60 days
could be less could be more that's up to
you and I think you could put this I
believe Mr Thompson that we when we went
over
this the
license
doesn't you can you the lapse occurs one
year after the expiration date so there
should be no problem
whatsoever within a day or a month and
if that's not clear enough perhaps we
should consider tweaking the language
because I think that's the intent that
okay we definitely don't want to
penalize someone you know if they mail
in their license and and it gets lost in
the mail and they have to try again a
week later yes representative gr you
have an answer
well I have a comment I don't think the
so what we don't want to have happen if
someone doesn't renew because everyone's
responsible for getting their license
renewed at a particular time because
they all know when their license is
going to expire what we don't want is
someone to realize that they haven't
renewed their license and then it's
reinstated and then it's backdated to
the time that it should have been
because that they didn't have a license
then so I think that that's one of the
things we have to consider when we
um discuss this the intent is not for
that to
happen right right so I think the only
go back to my my car inspection uh
analogy is that you do have 10 days
after your birthday month to get your
car inspected and you can still drive it
legally so we're just trying to make
sure that there is there is times where
you do forget uh your renewal dat um and
so we were just asking for some grace
period there but I do also understand
the portion of of not having a license
during that that 30 to 60 day period so
I I just I don't know I don't have a
fixed rate this second but I just was
asked to convey that there should be
some grace period okay well it appears
that there is a one-year grace period to
be able to reinstate the license without
penalty you're but it doesn't start you
you don't cover the it doesn't cover the
period of time where you hadn't renewed
it okay and if that and I believe this
is a sort of fine print that is normally
covered in the r broken out in the rule
so I hope you will read it
representative representative leus thank
you I'm just trying to clarify my
understanding the process and maybe
somebody from oplc will end up answering
but so if you don't get it renewed by
the
expiration then you're you're operating
without a license for some period of
time which is illegal I guess and so the
question is yeah you I mean you can get
it or reinstated by paying the extra 50
bucks but is somebody going to be
prosecuted for operating without a
license during that period and and I
don't see anything that says you
wouldn't
be or is that
rules so I can explain uh representative
leas uh how it works um right now which
is uh if somebody files an application
for reinstatement one of the questions
is have have you practice without a
license and if they answer yes we still
proceed with reinstatement because
they've met the minimum qualifications
to have the license but it gets referred
over to enforcement for potential
inquiry into whether or not there should
be
discipline usually when that happens and
the Board of Nursing has the set forth
in rules um they go through disciplinary
process and they're issued either after
a settlement agreement or hearing an
administrative fine for practicing
without a license but if you if you just
let your license expire you know you
took 3 months off and then decided to
reinstate and you didn't practice there
wouldn't be that display plenary process
the boards used to hold up somebody's
reinstatement if somebody answered yes I
practice without a license and and use
it to consider whether or not they
should issue the license but from our
perspective that should never be really
a factor because the person has minimum
competency okay thank
you yes all right thank you and thank
you for that and I guess my last I
didn't get to ask Lindsay about director
Courtney about this but the on page uh
three line 10 I'll start above it says
the docket file for each such proceeding
shall be retained in accordance with the
retention policy established by oplc and
I just didn't know if it would be
prudent to either site where that
retention policy
is um that would be a good idea except
that we that the oplc and the Secretary
of St state are uh are working out
exactly who would be responsible for
that the the archist has given um the
oplc some guidelines which they are
using and enforcing but it's not really
their rule it's somebody else's rule
okay at at the moment this should get
you to it
okay that is all I had so well thank you
very much thank you representative gou
though might have a
question thank you madam chair I'm not
sure who this question goes to but I
wanted to make sure I was
understanding if a
liy forgets to get their renewal in on
time and then they oops and they get
their application into renew they have a
fee for
reinstatement is there also a penalty
were there two fees I I got confused a
little bit
there thank
you thank you representative gold so
there is a fee to get your license which
is if you're renewing it's the renewal
fee if you're reinstating it's the
reinstatement fee if you're getting your
initial license it's the initial license
application fee the only time a fine
comes into play is whether you've
practiced without a license because that
is misconduct and is considered
discipline thank
you any other representative
Schmid thank you mam chair so I I wonder
whether we need to give some more
thought to this idea of practicing
without a license because uh
you uh your license has expired and you
forgot about it or whatever but so much
of our lives are uh governed by what the
insurance companies will cover or not uh
and if you're outside of that insurance
coverage and there's a problem uh a
doctor makes a mistake has an accident
or whatever uh and and and they're in
that gray area where the license has
technically
expired um or or it's discovered
afterwards
oh he or she was practicing for maybe a
couple of months without the license and
then something happened I I I wonder if
we need to kind of try and think through
this maybe not to solve this particular
bills language at the moment but whether
we need to think it through a little bit
more and come up with a better situation
I mean for example my I I'm my birthday
is on May
29th okay so that means when May comes
around Bing I know I have to get my
license and my registration
my vehicle registration
renewed uh and I know you have 10 days
to get the car inspected after the
registration period but the registration
period the next day if I'm driving on
June 1st and I haven't re-registered my
vehicle I'm driving an illegal vehicle
if I I'm stopped or if I have an
accident and so forth um in my case as I
say I I I'm aware that I I have H an
obligation to re-register my vehicle but
somehow it's it's not really till the
29th of the month when my birthday is
that it it starts flashing red yes thank
and I've only got a couple of days
before the end of the month so it it
it's but the insurance aspect as I say
I'm just wonder whether we we could give
some more thought to something about is
there an additional period where the
license is I don't know director cartney
if someone submits
a renewal
application you know the day the day of
the expiration and the pro and it takes
a couple of days for processing is that
considered practicing without a license
no so and we are required to notify
lenses and we do notify lenes 60 days
prior to their uh expiration date that
they have to renew but under 541a 29a I
believe it is um as long as they submit
it prior to the expiration and it could
be 11:59 p.m. it will remain active in
our system as designated active renewal
until we process the
application um so they won't be
practicing without a
license okay so that as long as they've
gotten the application in by the end of
the before the expiration date they're
good yeah yes and however inconvenient
it is for the office right and as long
as they can demonstrate an intent or or
an attempt to renew we treat that as
coming under 541a 29a so if you know
they say that the system was not working
or the payment processing as long as
they demonstrate an an attempt we C we
count that as well okay thank you that's
reassuring representative ly thank you
uh with this is online filing you could
do it if the system is down or something
but if you mail it by snail mail it gets
lost so to have a proof is that
something that would be
considered
uh of that it was with intention of
doing it before the expiration like you
can say stamped but if the mail is
lost so I believe our current rules
require that um for paper applications
that it be
received by the expiration date
or um that is something that we could
consider changing although I will say
that we're gladly moving away from as a
matter of routine have our license
applications processed via paper um so
that may become a nonissue but that's
something that we can certainly consider
okay representative leus thank you uh so
the discussion of the motor vehicle
registration brought up a question that
is a motor vehicle registration you can
actually handle that the month before
your month of your birthday which is
what I usually do so how early can
someone start the renewal process before
the expiration 60 days representative
right thank you
okay which is when they are
reminded okay all
right than other
questions all right in that case I will
close the hearing I will will mention to
the committee that we are meeting to
vote on this on Wednesday so I'll see
you all then somebody G clean up the
language representative bro are you
taking care of these
much